all right Fritz yes how are you so where
are you from originally where'd you grow
up I grew up in Pennsylvania
um moved to Tampa and middle school and
then graduated high school went to
school in Mississippi
after that spent some time in West
Africa doing non-profit work after that
returned back to Tampa and kind of
started my career
and uh your childhood was tell me about
how you grew up I was pretty
conservative household
um I'm also adopted so I was kind of
just
floating around in the space where I
there's a lot of unknown that I didn't
understand
um I learned a lot my parents were very
open about
about the adoption
um you know I'm really blessed to have
been adopted by them and brought into a
good caring family
very conservative so
I I learned a lot when I went to college
I got to kind of flutter my wings and
and fly
um
yeah I mean it was it's a good childhood
it was it was great but my parents are
still super supportive
um
and and I've met a lot of people through
them that have kind of guided my way to
where I am now that's great and what do
you do for work I'm in Hospitality
management okay so
um I'm done events hotels restaurants
kind of a whole ball game right so how
did how did uh nudism come into your
life nudism so upon my return from West
Africa
um I
I had a lot of
just stuff pent up inside where I super
insecure about my life who I was my body
everything
um so one of my friends that I had known
through
through college high school
it's like yo we're playing in this naked
volleyball tournament
why don't you come check it out
and I'm like no no I can't do that
so every week for about a year and a
half she's like are you gonna come we
have another tournament coming up and
I'm like no I can't do it so probably
after about a year
I was like all right let's do it so I
went
um it was at Cypress Cove in Orlando
and first hour I was like oh my God like
there's so many naked people like I
didn't want to take off my clothes
um
and then we went out we had a couple
drinks
um we had listened to music
and from then on it's been like
take it off and just really show who you
are I met a lot of people through her
so many different different
groups and tribes that all stand for so
many different things but the coolest
part about
nudism is it's all about this
that's like
inclusion and and really just making
sure people's
people's Spirits are high you know you
don't have to be this
this like pinup model to be a good
person or to feel pretty or to feel
beautiful
um and so I learned a lot
of that coming to me
but now where I am today it's like
I exude that to other people and so any
chance I get to talk about
nudism to a non-nudist
and and let them realize like
you're not coming here
just because we wanted to get naked
you're coming into this community to
kind of find that that click and that
glue that holds you together it seems
like a very accepting Community it is I
mean everyone's just letting it all hang
out with absolutely they're just kind of
like we are who we are exactly no one's
no one's like sucking in their gut no
one's not pretending to be someone
they're not how does nudism affect your
life outside of a resort like when
you're at work and you're wearing
clothes and all that how does it affect
it does for me I I separate it a hundred
percent
um when I'm at work
and they're at work I'm gonna wear my
clothes
um no but but does it affect the way you
interact with others or or I don't see
people differently I don't think so
I could say if I see someone struggling
or struggling with an insecurity I can I
can read into that a lot or on the other
end of the spectrum someone who's super
Posh and snooty you know both of those
sides of the spectrum can benefit from
coming into
into something like this
I'm not necessarily going to bring it up
to them at work due to the nature of my
job
um but my brain my brain goes 24 7.
especially in social groups when I go
out socially in a non-nutist setting
all of my nudist friends that are out
with me are like this is weird like
we're all wearing clothes and we have to
put on makeup and we have to
um go out and buy outfits it's very
freeing to not have oh my God I'll come
here tonight to Paradise Lakes
and gym shorts and a tank top to go out
for the night you know it's dance and
drink and listen to the DJs
and I mean it makes life easy
we also do I mean they do a lot of
parties it's a theme party so we do get
dolled up and stuff but I I would say I
mean so many people on so many different
levels
can benefit from coming into a nudist
community
everybody has that same mindset of how
are you how can we make you feel
comfortable how can we make you feel
included
how can we help you make an impact on
other people's lives
by doing this and it is a big
misconception in regards to nudism
versus the lifestyle nudism
you know we push for for this community
to grow
because we want that that
I mean it's a family
you know I come here and sometimes I'm
the youngest person here by 30 years old
I'm gonna go out and dance with the
ladies I'm gonna go have a cocktail with
the guys
um
and being 30 and they're 65 or 70 but it
feels completely normal I mean we talk
about every time we come here like we
don't have to be out with people our age
group you could be out with 18 year olds
we could be out with 30 year olds 60
year olds
um
and it feels like a normal Night Out in
a club which is awesome I mean don't
find that in many communities what is
nudism about is is it about Freedom
that's right that's my good instinct
tells me that I think personally it
should be about freedom but I I think as
a whole
I wouldn't be where I am today or be as
comfortable as I am in myself
without that group backing that brought
me into this
so I can make an impact on people's
lives but my friends and my Affiliates
in this setting
like you can change you can it's gonna
sound cliche you can change the world
with it I mean there's so much
sadness and depression and
and stuff I mean
because I was there I mean and then I
found this and it's like holy [__] like
I'm so happy and I like never look back
I I I'm looking for
little
signs of
uh falseness or of of
hidden like emotions that are and it
just seems to me like everyone's
genuinely happy here I would love to say
no that's that's that's fake that's
that's but it's not it seems to be like
everyone yeah having a good time when
you first come into it you're like
there's got to be something hiding yeah
so that's I'm looking for something
hidden and it's not there I mean for
nudism we're like at our at our bear
nothing
um
and then on the lifestyle aspect about
it they operate it so well couples
Resorts where
those couples are so open and honest and
that's why
lifestyle works
right openness honesty integrity
if there's not that
you'll there'll be some stuff hidden
behind the doors
luckily I have not been a part of any of
that I know a lot of people that have
um and it and it hurts what this
community is about right because they
can be tied so too and two together
where it's like man I mean you just have
still so much love for him you want to
bring them back to that family
and uh
it stands it stems down to the openness
and honesty with everyone
so yeah it
and there's different
like subcultures in the nudist correct
Community right correct they're swingers
there's people that are just naturalists
yeah
and uh
it seems like there's a sexual component
but there sometimes is not correct so
naturism
the group the biggest group I'm a part
of is called tikitamba it's a big
volleyball group
um it started in 2007.
and it it was just a bunch of people
that loved volleyball uh came down here
found Como found paradise and
it boomed I mean we just had a huge
tournament in Pennsylvania
like probably four or five hundred
people and it's High Level Volleyball
you know we've we've either played in
college we played overseas some people
have played in high school some people
have never played so we were on a clinic
we run we run a tournament and it's like
it's better than normal clothes
volleyball
um and that side of it is so naturist
and free spirit like we'll do
breathing workshops we'll do volleyball
clinics we'll do
DJ sessions we'll have music love
volleyball cooking camping
um and and
this sexual aspect is is separated out
of that
um
on the opposite end you have Resorts you
know Paradise Lakes Caliente uh and it
is a lifestyle Resort
and we I mean I dive into it
a lot you know only because it you walk
in and it's like holy [__] this is so
cool we're naked we're dressed up
this guy's wife and husband and that
couple is all hooking up
um and they're so happy and they can
find happiness in that
for myself I don't know if I could find
happiness in it because I haven't tried
but it's for me it's awesome to see
just figuring out life just in this like
open book and free spirit floating
unicorns that we are
um
and when it works it's awesome
um but it definitely is a huge huge
split
if I'm going out for a normal day
during the day at Paradise or Como
I'm not looking nor do I expect to see
any of
the lifestyle or swinger stuff
at night Paradise Caliente absolutely
Como is a family-friendly Resort you
know so if I saw there I'd probably tell
them to stop
um only because you have to respect you
know nudism does not start
once you become an adult you know the
naturists
start as kids I mean I have friends that
their families and their kids are all
naked from their when they're born yeah
um and watching even those kids grow up
five six seven years old just run around
in the field naked while we're playing
volleyball naked it's amazing I mean
it's like
and I think it creates such such a
bigger Bond
I also don't have kids so I can't speak
from experience but what I've seen with
the children and their moms or children
they are Gods it's like this solid Bond
but those kids also bond with the rest
of our community
right so my one of my good friends son
seven years old will run around
we'll play tag hide and seek and he just
face planted the dirt roll around in the
dirt it's like that Primal Instinct of
like being naked and how we were how we
were supposed to be it's really really
cool do you think most of the US is is
uptight about sex or nudity and all that
I think where we are now is a lot more
open especially in regards to sex I
think
I think nudity
I mean man
I think people are misinformed on what
nudity is therefore their brain ticks
well I mean you hear a nudist resort you
immediately an outsider will think
deviant Behavior correct absolutely a
bunch of perverts there are tons of
misconceptions about it
every time I say I'm going to a nudist
volleyball tournament or nudists this
people who
have never come will always say
enjoy your orgy or enjoy this so enjoy
that
and I'm like I mean it's not necessarily
um
it's definitely a misconception it seems
like you know I've only been here
for a day or two but it seems like it's
very
you can take it or leave it you don't
there's no pressure to do anything you
don't want to do no I
Paradise does such a good job because I
mean you're diving further into nudist
resorts right
Paradise is clothing optional
so I've brought
I don't even want to know I mean 50 to
100 of my non-nutist friends that I
didn't know before I became a nudist
into the nudist Community some of them
are now nudists with me some of them
will come here and still not take their
clothes off but it's not a problem but
this being a clothing optional Resort
you know you can you can get into the
pool with your board shorts so you can
get into the pool with your bikini and
go at your own pace and and that's
that is like a key focal point in making
our community grow
because that does make those those
newcomers feel accepted feel like
they're going at their own pace the
acceptance is a big deal here I think I
think I mean that's what would make
somebody open up and relax with it
because if you felt pressure you must be
naked
you're not going to do it absolutely but
if you just you can you can you you can
go in the pool with your swim you know
something to sit down and no one's going
to say dude correct here yeah here most
resorts
or if you are in the water you do have
to be completely nude
um
so I always bring people here first
um it says my second Resort that I came
to but some of the resorts are a little
more sexualized no I mean even
Como I mean como is family friendly yep
and
you can't even be in Bottoms
uh around the pool deck at all no matter
what really so
and I've taken people to Como that
aren't necessarily 100 ready to dive in
and
and it it can
stray them away from it you know and we
have to have the talk you know like
that's not what it's about
I want you here because I want you to
feel acceptance and love from this group
of people if there's any point when
you're when you're out of nudist resort
where
you don't feel that then we're doing
something wrong it's not
you it's not the new person
it's our job to push
acceptance and boost
turn those insecurities into strength
because you never know who the next
non-nudist is that's that's going to
come in and probably struggle with the
same [__]
um
and I think that's what I've learned the
most about
being a nudist is like
you can be open and transparent with
your body
um but
to really grow and
and and get to that place
of like
like
I'm good with who I am right
you have to open this up and be
transparent with this and God I'm gonna
cry
um you feel like honesty is is the way
to yeah I mean
if you open up your brain and let this
community
know what you're going through
um
there they've got your back right and
then you grow that's great and the next
person comes in and I'm going to do that
for someone else and it's like
it's a breath of fresh air you know it's
I me
and I'm happy with being me now do you
feel like you're you're more accepting
of who you are and 100 able to love
yourself better absolutely because of
this I mean I wouldn't be here if it
wasn't for nudism
I'd be probably in the ground or if my
options would be in the ocean somewhere
because I didn't know who I was
um
so the group of people that brought me
into it are still that rock
um
but it's been awesome because I've grown
so much and I still struggle with stuff
um but when when these new people come
in I see myself in them sometimes and
all you can do is be like it gets better
bro like
and I'm here for it
um
and then all I can hope is it trickles
down to the Next Generation
Um and it's
it really is that breath and fresh air I
mean this unconventional to hear from a
nudist
um but
it's it is life-changing and it makes a
huge impact on the world so it's great
fruits well thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you I
appreciate you yeah your take on it is
very
you know it's it's deep yeah it is yeah
it is on so many different levels yeah
I was like I'm not gonna cry in this I
wasn't prepared for it I know
thank you